people are social animals they have
choice
so people analytics is not like
measurement on a grand prix car it is
it's the social sciences the psychology
bet so it's directional it's
patent-based it's uh you know
likelihoods and probabilities it's not
if you do x you will get y anybody who
comes into people analytics with a sort
of prescriptive binary mindset is going
to fail um
whilst behavior of a population may be
true that does not mean an individual
will match that
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
we're going to be talking about people
today and people analytics meet ian cook
vice president of people analytics at
vizier inc
ian cook is recognized for his
leadership and insight in the era of
workforce analytics and planning ian is
currently the vice president of people
analytics at vizier where he helps
customers drive organizational change
through linking workforce analysis to
business outcomes he is responsible for
the workforce domain expertise within
the visio solutions prior to joining
vizier ian built canada's leading source
of hr benchmarking data his knowledge
and expertise come from 10 plus years of
consulting with global companies and he
holds an ma from edinburgh university in
the uk and an mba from lancaster
university also in the uk
ian cook so great to have you here on 20
minute leaders how are you
i'm very well thank you michael how's
yourself
good good morning to you from vancouver
good afternoon to me from tel aviv
i'm excited to talk about you know human
resources people analytics what does
that even mean to be vice president of
people analytics you know within vizier
talking about your own journey your own
fascination with hr
and you know obviously a postcode and
you know now that we're rehabilitating
the workforce and what's happening it's
a it's more relevant than ever to be
speaking about this topic and so we'll
dive into that in just a bit but i'd
love to spend a little bit of time
getting to know you better tell me a
little bit about your journey and
specifically your fascination with human
resources
my fascination with human resources
started right back when i was in my
teenage years um doing expeditions and
working with teams and identifying that
some teams really knock out the park in
terms of what they can do and how fast
and how easy it is and other teams just
suck
and so i was always fascinated by how do
you get a group of people together to
make something great
and and
really there's there's so many layers to
that it's a really fascinating problem
so
it's one of you know human resources is
a piece of it organizational development
is a piece of it um so i was always
fascinated with the people side of
business and that sort of leads you into
you know working in the hr space so i
kind of had that fascination didn't
really understand what it meant but i
just chased it my career and here i am
today in the people out like space
so so what does the career in the human
resources space look like what are the
different options and which one did you
opt into
so there's a number of streams there's a
fairly traditional stream through what's
called a generalist where you're you're
in the business in a consulting mode and
you're helping people navigate policy um
there's the centers of excellence where
you're designing leadership programs
designing time management programs
recruiting and then there's leadership
roles there's also a track which is
called organizational development or
organizational effectiveness which is
really about that's more the track that
i've followed which is like how do you
help people give of their best how do
you design understand talent how do you
shape the organization to be this um
performance oriented group i think of it
i am scottish but i live in canada a
hockey team is is a huge thing and so i
think of it about how do you put the
best team on the ice at the right price
that monkey has a cost cap so it's a
good way to think about a business you
want to spend as little as possible for
as much output as possible
so
vice president of people analytics at
vzr
what does that even mean what does that
even mean exactly what does that mean
what is the jobs i don't mean anyway
what i do daily michael is i
i am focused on trying to understand the
the the business challenges that that
are organizations have that are kind of
clear and present
how the application of data can bring
answers to those questions um and then
how that would drive our product
strategy how that would drive some of
our marketing and then evangelizing in
the market helping people understand
there's still exactly as you highlight
this there's still this huge gap between
oh people on excite oh we we count the
number of performance management reviews
that have happened no that's not what
we're doing what we're doing is
understanding what is causing people to
leave our business or what is causing us
to miss you know production targets
they're related to people and we're
using that to inform the business to
make a better decision
you know looking at simple things like
um
women leaving a particular shift because
it doesn't match their work expectations
or doesn't match their needs for work so
rather than saying oh we'll just people
with men let's change the shift patterns
and let's have that conversation with
the data with the business and say we're
losing the capacity to run this shift
because of how we've chosen to make our
work structures if we change our work
structures we'll be back to productive
best again we just have to think about
that
you know either take this example or or
choose a different whatever you prefer
but but dive deeper into you know what
does it mean to to do people analytics
and to leverage this data leverage these
you know critical thinking habits to
then go and optimize for for a better
workforce habit better experience for
the employees which at the end you know
amount to
better
you know better performance for the
whole company how does that process from
your seat look but also how does that
process for the rest of the people look
within your organization are they aware
of what you do
are they aware of your function are do
are they cooperative are they you know
more hesitant how does it work
yeah the vizier's whole business is
focused on on people analytics and
helping the organizations in the market
do it so if i if i use the example of
some of our clients how this works is
they they
go into the business as a consultant and
say
where are you running into issues where
have you got friction
and specifically related to people
then they walk that back and say well
what data do we have
you know hr has been digitizing like
marketing like sales in the past it's
been digitizing so there's this exhaust
set of how do people feel about work how
much work have they done when are they
coming to work right so the analytics
group looks at that data set and says
what patents can we find that will help
us change things so again another client
that we work with they're looking at um
they're starting to look at uh calendar
data
and then pinging people saying you know
you haven't got any focus time blocks in
here you're you're scheduling meetings
so close together that your
your ability to do productive work is
being hindered and it's a gentle nudge
it's not like you know thou shalt but
it's that kind of how do we help people
give of their best what data do we have
what questions do we answer and so
we're in the technology business of
building an application that helps our
customers do that so they can
you know put the right pieces in front
of the right people
right and so
how often is it that you know that you
have the the ceos or the leadership
teams coming and you know it sounds to
me that many in many cases they're
coming in with a problem that they're
feeling that there is a problem and then
going and backtracking and fixing it so
how many of these are sort of
preventable from the get-go and what
does this mean for you know me as a
young entrepreneur or for some of my
friends that are young entrepreneurs
what do we need to do from the get-go to
sort of be on top of these things and
not reach a point where we need to go
and do crisis management on something
you know a great question um and this
totally tracks the evolution of
people it used to be called hr metrics
when i first started 20 years ago and
then it became um
hr analytics and then it became people
analytics and
the reason for that journey is this
notion of
instead of measuring things once they're
done lots of people develop policy
in a box and as a thought experiment so
as you're a young entrepreneur you're
thinking like how is my culture how are
we going to shape
the experience of work so that people do
their best
it's actually giving it time and intent
and running potentially running
experiments potentially looking at the
the the research or looking at your own
numbers to say this is working for us
this isn't so that the shift in people
alex has been from kind of like
accounting in the past where here's how
much money we made to what would be an
fp a
group which would be like here's how
we're going to make more money so it's
it's actually injecting the data at the
front end and if you
start a business
um you don't always have the data but
you can look at what others are doing
you can look at what their data is
saying what the labor market is telling
you to say hey this is this would work
this wouldn't work so it's being
not it's being intentional about your
people strategy from the get-go um and
building it out as a as an intentional
piece of how your business works as
opposed to just letting it fall into
place because we're just excited and we
think it's cool and off we go um that
some of that will work so that won't
work and then you run into trouble where
you have to
retroactively adjust things further down
the line as you scale that can cause a
lot of friction
now
is there a line of tension
is there a line of tension between this
concept of
you know analytics and people and at the
end you know
analytics about you know some behavior
and then amending that behavior based on
the analytics and then that obviously
affecting the people is this thing is
this even a line of thought or or are we
past that point and we're accepting that
it's all data-driven
no it's totally a line of thought and
it's more a case of
coming with the right lens to people
analytics like people are social animals
they have choice so people analytics is
not like measurement on a grand prix car
it is it's the social sciences the
psychology bet so it's directional it's
patent-based it's uh you know
likelihoods and probabilities it's not
if you do x you will get y anybody who
comes into people analytics with a sort
of prescriptive binary mindset is going
to fail um
whilst behavior of a population may be
true that does not mean an individual
will match that
um so you you have to first of all have
a strong ethical component we talk a lot
about ethics
what is okay to use data for what's not
okay we have a really strong stance on
that so you have to start with that
baseline and then it's about you know
how are we using this data
not just for the business perspective
against the people but with the business
with the people so it's actually looking
at how do we make things better
this is the stories i like me we have
countless stories of
um changes and policy that have led to
opportunity for people of color led to
opportunity for women
i love cases so
share with me share with you
quick story you know
classic classic story for a business
there's a business line that is not
producing the revenue so finance come
along and say we gotta cut people
you know hr please get ready to hand out
the the what we call a pink slip it's
the termination slip you're you're no
longer employed
people alex team comes in and says oh no
stop the bus huge reputational risk in
terminating people like that goes
through the community that damages our
hiring that does not set our brand up
well and
we our brand is our community
let us do some numbers so they look at
the numbers they look at retirement
rates they look at natural exit rates
they look at how people are moving out
of business anyway they say we can get
to your number
two weeks later
if we just let it happen naturally
ceo says let's just let it happen
naturally so they don't they don't
terminate anybody they don't do any of
that process of sitting down and having
that uncomfortable conversation of sorry
you're no longer employed they just get
to their cost bar
as finance required through uh the
natural process of the business
finance can't see that they can't make
that decision the people alex team is
the balance it's the really crucial
second piece of the puzzle that means
those things can happen so i love that
story because it's win for the business
you know we shouldn't underestimate the
reputational damage that comes
um so who knows how much revenue they
would have lost how many customers like
you fired my friend i'm taking all my
banking away from you
definitely for and there's a whole bunch
of other roll-ons you get contagion when
you let people go other people fear for
their jobs they will also leave so you
will always overshoot so there's always
again
it's a really rich simple story because
most people
run the decision on the finance you need
to run in the decision on the finance
and the people it's never
one or the other so that's a key piece
that's fine so i'd love to there's
there's another question that i'd love
to to hear from but and then i'd like to
leave some time to ask you a little bit
more about yourself but but please do
share another one
this this is um
again in the diversity space the
this is again ceo driven there's been
changes in the regulations in the u.s
through the sec where publicly traded
companies need to now make commentary
about their human capital and so
diversity is a key part of that
buying behavior has changed such that
your stance on social justice will
actually determine whether people buy
you or not
so many ceos are making
forward-looking statements about
what their numbers are going to be
we've had several analytics teams who've
then been kind of key part of that
conversation well this is our
representation now but this is how it
changes based on mobility based on
movement up through the business
what that has led to is a recognition by
the organization of the need to create
pathways to growth
it's an economic
opportunity
factor so
those organizations have said well we're
going to hit these numbers that means we
need to um enable everybody to have
access to learning enable more people
have access to supervisory roles you
know actually build diversity up through
the business um so it's still
merit-based but but we're pushing the
opportunity to everybody so that we
build diversity organically in the
business
again if you read anything there was a
great article by mckinsey just yesterday
around you know the the secret about
diversity as better quality jobs was the
title
and this research
done by this analytics team basically
was you know convincing the ceo of it
which then brings the budget which then
brings change so it fundamentally alters
how the business performs
uh
and it does
the right things by the people in the
community so it's it is a win-win it's
the kind of world where we're now
working i believe we're working in we're
um
talking about the labor market you know
employees have a lot of choice right now
so
how you treat them matters
and those kinds of stories are go a long
way to bringing in you know good talent
right now as you're thinking through
these stories and as you're reflecting
on you know where we are today what
where where is
people in the lakes headed where is hr
tech and
specifically you know looking at
data-driven decision-making for the
workforce where are we heading with this
we've we've got a research-based model
around value the really simple inputs
the more different pieces of information
you can integrate
the more people who can consume it the
better it's it's kind of that simple
what we're seeing with the shift of
hybrid work um which we think is going
to persist in a large number of places
where it can is managers don't have that
tooling like i think about our marketing
team
you know the tracking clicks which i can
click throughs that the amount they're
tracking that they have to understand
and adjust how their work works
managers don't have that
tool set around look looking after and
working with their people
so we've seen it in some of our early
adopter early driver customers where the
the data starts to flow out to people
manager not lots and lots of kind of
activity tracking but here's the things
that you need to know in order to take
action to keep the right employee to
make sure promotions are done fairly to
make sure that you assemble a team
that's actually going to get that piece
of work done
so it's not again there's been this
whole manager enablement thing mostly
that was making it easy to sign off on
time off like that's the hr
transactional systems you know we made
it look good to say yes i appreciate
time off that's not that's admin that's
not really relevant this next wave will
be effectiveness it's like you know
you're
you lost a key player that means the
experience in your team is is below what
you need you're going to have to find a
good level replacement in order to keep
this team productive that's likely an
internal transfer because the ramp time
of a new person is too slow
and so it's that kind of insight in the
manager's hands
so that they're they're
you know always focused on what do i
have to get done but it's helping them
understand how that people piece can put
friction in that work or accelerate that
work
we see the very starting edges of that
we know there's a huge amount of
opportunity huge amount of questions to
answer in there
we're engaged with our customers and
helping them get there and and go
further
i love it i love it and i'd love to take
you back a little bit to you know back
back to you and talk to me a little bit
about your childhood and you know
upbringing
what really fascinates you what really
sparks your curiosity
you know before you know that you're
gonna go into human resources
uh um
i was
school-wise i had a mixed bag i i liked
physics and i liked english
so i have a i had a mad brain
communication
it was a bizarre combination um and then
you know
and
i didn't really know that um
the the world of organizational
effectiveness existed so i kind of fell
into that through um
through working with teams and working
in groups and working on expeditions and
stuff like that so that was that
fascination and and i love bicycles i um
i have
right from the get-go bicycle was this
freedom machine for me and uh that that
endures now
with a shed full of them in my current
life so
i love it if and if you had to look
today and you know where do you draw
your inspiration from you know in the
day-to-day life where where is it coming
from
so a lot of the inspiration is actually
coming from the the community that i'm
part of there there are
numerous people that i engage with on a
daily basis
see the
world of workload i see it that it's a
balance between people and business and
those two things are not mutually
exclusive it's not a case of win loss
it's a case of win-win um and they're
working hard every day to help explain
that communicate that build that build
the practices around it so the
again really my inspiration comes from
being part of that community of people
who are
making a human-centered business
um and then
you feel the scottish accent like i'm
not
in any way shape or form let's give up
on making money i i think that's an
absolutely essential piece
but there's there are better ways to do
it than at the expense of others so it's
that kind of balance point um
and so yeah i draw that inspiration from
those folks
and if you had to choose three words or
a few words that you would use to
describe yourself
i i have those three words um inside
understanding and joy like it was a
early phase in my career where i didn't
like what i was doing i didn't like what
my manager was and that you know i had
those
um dark moments in it that come to any
career so i had to find the three words
that made
me want to go to work
um and so they are insight understanding
and joy
ian thank you very very much this was so
great thank you for sharing you know
your insights and your time with me i
really appreciate it
and uh
and i'm really really excited to share
this with with the world and think more
critically about human resources and
data-driven decisions
and i'm just very thankful that you were
here so thank you very very much and
stay safe and stay healthy
yeah thanks michael it's been it's been
a pleasure to talk to you
thank you thank you very much